jim fin après c'est à vous bonjour
chantal jouanno est ce qu'on va parler
de la primaire de la droite ou de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
c'est la grande question qui va trancher
notamment ce week-end lors du congrès de
l'udps et lit les militants étaient
appelés à voter jusqu'à jusqu'à demain
ça semble assez mal embarquée pour tout
dire puisqu'on on entendait encore ce
matin jean christophe lagarde appelé les
adhérents à refuser cette primaire ils
lui réclament des gages aux républicains
sur la question de la ligne sur la
question des places aux législatives le
bras de fer est ce que c'est la bonne
façon de procéder sur cette question là
on a un partenaire parce qu'on a la
lutte et il s'est toujours inscrite
comme effectivement partis partenaires
mais pas un parti subalternes ou soumis
ça c'est une grande différence par
rapport à la tradition passé on a un
parti partenaire qui nous dit grosso
modo venez venez parce que la menace du
front national est telle qu'on peut pas
partir divisés
on n'est pas en exhibant qu on leur a
écrit on leur a dit qu'on commence à
discuter délégation a délégation avec
plusieurs représentants des républicains
de leur côté et nous on avait plusieurs
représentants de de lui dit
ces discussions n'ont jamais eu lieu ja
de la photokina nicolas sarkozy la balle
est dans leur camp on était prêts on
leur a écrit les discussions n'ont
jamais la faute à qui on va pas
personnalisé c'est globalement les
républicains parce qu'ils étaient tous
au courant c'est un fait globalement les
airs tout d'un coup c'est assez marrant
parce que comme du coup on aura des bois
moi très bien on va poser la question
telle quelle à nos militants puisque
c'était notre engagement on a toujours
dit que maintenant cédées sont les
militants qui vont décider donc on leur
pose la question je sens l'absence
d'accord puisqu'il n'y a pas d'accord
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on participe à la
primaire mais nos militants ils sont ils
sont attachés à lui dit non et c'est
probable c'est probable moi je réglais
que le choix des militants ils sont
encore en train de voter mais sur le
fond vous est ce que
dans ce décor élan tout de toutes ces
questions de lignes et de place aux
législatives
est ce que vous vous êtes pour un
candidat udi dans ce système de
primaires oui ou non à la aujourd'hui
alors qu'il n'y a aucun accord sur la
ligne aucun pires qu'on est fédéraliste
est ce qu'on est d'accord sur le fait de
simplement qu'on porte sur l'obligation
d'avoir mes seins candidats là vous
raisonnez en comptabilité politiques
comme les républicains aujourd'hui nous
on vous parle de fond est ce que on est
d'accord pour dire que l'europe c'est
une priorité ou pas moi c'est ça mon
sujet il est là et ça n'a parlé de fond
les républicains ne parle pas de fonds à
baho écouter ils ont pas vous mieux
répondre jamais par le moi je leur dis
mais écoutez franchement venez pas nous
reprocher le fait de pas participer
alors que vous ne nous avait jamais
accepté à la table des négociations
ce sera probablement parce que moi je
suis une aide directe
nous allons à différentes composantes
pour quoi ça sert de l'algérie comme ça
c'est comme à l'ump il ya différentes
têtes tête de figure moi je suis dirigé
à chaque fois que j'ai rencontré les
militants de l'udps et ils sont 1
radicalement indépendantiste vraiment
ils sont opposés à toute forme de
soumission et à cette espèce de chantage
sur si vous venez pas on va être divisé
c'est pas bien est ce que ça veut dire
que si les adhérents refus ce week end
le système la première ce sera défini
mon difficile définitivement pardon
terminé qui aura pas de candidat la
question telle qu'elle est posée c'est
comme n'y a pas d'accord enfin l'absence
d'accord est ce qu'on participe si
demain tout d'un coup parce que là tout
d'un coup ils sont très agités
tout d'un coup il y à un accord on
reposera la question militants notre
engagement c'est pas à tête de partis à
tête de partie nous on demande à nos
micros bien d'être dans la négociation
c'est pas une première étape après
honnêtement va voir ce qu'ils proposent
parce que là haut sur la plupart des
candidats ils sont très intéressés à
nous dire si si on discute on va
discuter après alors par parlons
d'emmanuel coste c'était votre
adversaire lors des élections régionales
à l'issue desquels elle a été réélue
conseil régional adversaire j'étais
content de france concurrente alors
entre temps on l'a vu à les rentrer
gouvernement et visiblement ça lag à ce
qu'on puisse lui reprocher en son cumul
entre sa fonction ministérielle et son
mandat local de conseil régional qui
rappelons le ce cumul n'est pas interdit
en tout cas fait vous avez été élu en
disant je serai la seule liste non cumul
et vous cumulez pas de mandat mais rld à
linge sur des fils de cu maintenant je
joue pas sur les mots c'est vous qui
comprenait pas je comprends très bien
que vous cumulez incroyable questions
très simples chantal jouanno est ce que
emmanuelle cosse tout comme jean vincent
placé par exemple doit démissionner de
son mandat de conseil régional pour se
consacrer intégralement à ses fonctions
ministérielles
mais en fait ce qui se passe pourquoi
est-ce que vous arrêtez pas de les
titiller comme ça c'est comme quand il
était avant dans l'opposition ils
n'arrêtaient pas de nous dire mais vous
vous c'est inadmissible parce que moi
j'ai été ministre et conseiller régional
et j h mais jai jamais dit je vais
démissionner je vais tout à fait assumée
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai pas pris dans
les dents sur le thème c'est une amie si
vous êtes miss vous êtes ministre vous
cumulez horizon qui n'arrêtait pas là
tout d'un coup c'est comme le pauvre
singes avec sa main coincée avec savanna
et se retrouve dans la même situation
donc voila vous l'avez dit le cumul pour
l'instant n'est pas interdit
effectivement c'est pas une intéressant
non plus pour un ministre de conserver
un pied dans la réalité la dystrophine
âge pas certains ministres d'être en
même temps président de région
d'ailleurs donc aujourd'hui moi c'est
mais c'est autant l'assumer qu'est ce
qui se passe pour emmanuel point c'est
quand elle a été tellement tellement
violente sur ce cumul des mandats que
aujourd'hui bas ça se retourne
effectivement un petit peu comme une
contrainte
comme quoi il faut toujours être un peu
modeste dans nos positions dans une
tribune au figaro ce matin nicolas
sarkozy s'insurge contre le choix de
françois hollande de commémorer demain
19 mars le cessez le feu de la guerre
d'algérie
c'est une date qui fait pas l'unanimité
pour moi parce que après cette date il
ya eu des massages encore beaucoup
d'exactions
deux dards qui est aujourd'hui des
familles s'insurge contre eux entre
cette commémoration est ce que c'est une
erreur de jugement de la part de
l'elysée
je comprends très mal pourquoi françois
hollande surtout aujourd'hui c'est ça
vraiment très mal parce que le président
de la république surtout sur une date de
commémoration ça a vocation à rassembler
à créer effectivement une mémoire
collective partagée ce problème de cette
date
moi j'ai beaucoup l'occasion de travail
de sur la question des harkis
ça a été atroce la suite a été atroce
avec une france l'acteur la guerre a
continué ces gens se faisaient massacrer
mais vraiment massacrés alors qu'il
portait le drapeau de la france dans
leur coeur et c'est pour ça avant moi
vis à vis des amas vis-à-vis des arcs et
que j'ai beaucoup suivi samassa me
blesse moi je suis pas requis mais j'ai
beaucoup suivi cette question là dans
une vie antérieure
et pour eux je trouve ça très douloureux
donc on fait plaisir à ses grands mais
c'est super qu'ils ont fait plaisir
c'est mais je pense que c'est c'est mal
pesé qu enfin pour un président de la
république aujourd'hui dans un pays qui
est quand même à a besoin de
rassemblement
quelle tristesse nicolas sarkozy parle
de guerre des mémoires 75 ans après on
est les plaies ne sont toujours pas
refermées on a toujours ces débats là en
france
est ce qu'on a toujours des membres dans
les familles qui ont vécu ça parce que
il ya quand même effectivement pour la
france vis-à-vis des harkis toujours une
question de bah oui oui c'est quand même
ça s'était toujours là pas réglé fut
question dernière question mardi soir
une réunion d'information sur
l'installation d'un centre d'hébergement
pour sdf dans le 16e arrondissement a eu
lieu ça a été très très très très chaud
ça a été perturbée par certains
riverains qui n'ont pas hésité à
insulter les élus de la mairie de paris
et les représentants de la préfecture
est ce que vous dénoncez cette attitude
ou est ce que vous comprenez les
inquiétudes des habitants du 16e
arrondissement
il ya eu des mots qui n'ont pas leur
place dans des débats publics
franchement les débats publics sont
faits là pour effectivement réfléchir
ensemble pas pour être aussi
durée parfois caricaturales ensuite
c'est vrai que la mairie de paris joue
beaucoup la provocation c'est au dos et
quand j'entends anne hidalgo c'est
vraiment alors là vous allez voir dans
le xvième c'est parce que comme vous
connaissez pas la vraie vie on va vous
apprendre ce que c'est que là la vraie
vie moi j'ai un sujet c'est la défense
absolue de la préservation des espaces
qui sont les si rare les espaces non le
droit de boulogne parce que on le
grignote jour après jour ce pauvre ce
pauvre bois de boulogne après qu'il ait
des centres de effectivement pour
accueillir des personnes défavorisées
partout c'est parfaitement normal donc
soit sur le principe d'accueillir les
personnes défavorisées au contraire
c'est parfaitement
c'est parfaitement normal parce que tu
as fait pour la nécessité du nord
surtout pas sur les haies qu'il veut
dire au final c'est tellement rare ans
alors en tout cas surtout sur paris et
en ile de france en général on en perd
en permanence quoi donc au final plutôt
pour mes problèmes de méthode problème
de fond de moi j'ai déjà entendu avec
les jeunes vraiment c'était on va mettre
de l'huile sur le feu ce que plus ça va
réagir au mieux ce sera